[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
telou on sait que les les relations
entre les responsables de la France et
du Maroc sont des relations actuellement
un peu tendues c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire et pourtant et pourtant les deux
pays les deux peuples sont entretiennent
une amitié qui est assez singulière un
peu différente de ce qui existe par
exemple entre la France et
l'Algérie tout à fait d'autant plus que
les deux peuples s'apprécie
s'estime des relations amicales ouais
bon là nous vivons une une crise qui
vient d'en haut Oui au niveau des chefs
des deux chefs d'État oui et je crois
que c'est la première fois qu'on vit une
crise aussi
grave du pour dire les choses clairement
maladresse de président Macron oui qui
n'a pas compris à qui il avait affaire
vous parlez de Mohamed 6 oui Mohamed 6
dès le départ d qu' est arrivé à
l'Élysée ça je l'ai su par des amis qui
travaillent avec lui il il a donné
priorité au dossier algérien ouais et il
a voulu faire ce que réussir là où ces
presque décesseurs ont échoué
c'est-àdire que lui va être plus fort il
va faire l'impossible c'est-à-dire que
la page franco-algérienne se tourne et
qu'on établisse des relations normales
sans culpabilité sans rentre mémoriale
et ressentiment il se trompe
ouais il se trompe et
le Maroc n'a jamais culpabilisé personne
et il avait en face de lui un monarque
qui n'est pas un monarque symbolique
c'est un monarque qui gouverne et qui a
une légimité depuis des siècles et qui
est adoré par le peuple marocain c'est
le royaume
chérifien mais réellement les le peuple
adore son
roi bon donc du temps de son père
c'était autre chose mais là Mohamed il
est adoré il aimé beaucoup aimé et il
n'a pas compris comment on parle à un
roi
ouais enfin bon tout tout est partie des
des écoutes Pegasus péasus c'est-à-dire
que il
accuse justement la monarchie marocaine
de l'avoir écouté avec un système
israélien d'ailleurs ouais alors d'abord
tous lesis tous les États du monde
sécoutent les uns les autres surveille
bon ben tout le monde s'écoute bon c'est
pas c'est pas la question la question
c'est que il a accusé le roi de l'avoir
fait écouter spécialement
lui le roi lui a dit je vous donne ma
parole que je vous ai pas fait
écouter et Macron lui dit j'ai des
preuves le roi lui répète je ne vous ai
pas fait écouter et là il lui fait il
lui dit quelque chose de très
désagréable qu' ne dit pas ni d'ailleurs
un chef d'État ni un ni un premier
ministre ni à personne quoi h il était
très désobligeant et vis-à-vis du roi il
aura arrêter la discussion nette comment
vous expliquez que avec le président
Trump bah le Maroc a signé les accords
ce qu'on appelaé les accords d'Abraham
c'est-à-dire que ils ont renoué des
relations
diplomatiques avec Israël aussi en
échange de quoi d'ailleurs les
États-Unis
reconnaissent la marocanité du Sahara
occidental mais pas la France est-ce que
ça aussi ça a joué jou parceil était pas
au courant oui pas pas été mis au
courant et en fait ceux qui ont le plus
travaillé les accords d'Abraham ce sont
quelques israéliens
ouais Trump ne connaît pas bien le le le
dossier connait pas le Maroc mais il a
dit ok Banou hm hm d'autant plus
qu'après il y a les Émirats arabes et ca
et Israël a bien joué AR h bien joué et
ça a été contrairement à ce qu'on
pensait ça a été très bien reçu par le
peuple marocain ouais d'abord parce
qu'il y a on a vraiment une très grande
proximité avec la communauté juive
marocaines qui est en Israël et ailleurs
dans le monde et qui revient très très
souvent au Maroc en tant que touriste
c'est des pays arabe où il y a la plus
grosse communauté juive éta la plus
grosseou maintenant à peu près 5000 mais
il y a un million de touristes chose
ouis et puis on a on a des choses en
commun on a on a beaucoup de de une
culture commune hm hm une culture une
civilisation une
cohabitation c'est on n pas fait la
guerre c'est pas l'Égypte c'est pas la
Jordanie c'est pas le Liban donc on est
on a une relation euh disons assez assz
assez riche et et finalement même si le
roi est président du comité Crots de
Jérusalem on reste vigilant vis-à-vis de
la question palestinienne c'est ça alors
euh je voudrais qu'on revienne parce que
on a parlé des dirigeants des deux pays
mais en revanche si on regarde bien
l'histoire des deux peuples justement
euh bah c'est plutôt des bonnes
relations puisque a toujours été des
bonnes relations mais on parlait de en
56 à l'indépendance on parlait de
l'indépendance dans
l'interdépendancependance
mais la première grande crise qui est
avit beaucoup plus grave que celle-ci
c'est laaffaire barkaa ouais éit donc
opposant
de GO était avait très très très mal
pris c'est une histoire qui s'est très
très mal passée qui qui s'est terminé
par la mort du pauvre bar 1965 oui 29
octobre le le roi avait demandé à
ramène-moi Medy parce Ben Barka opposant
politique oui était opposant et il était
son prof de math h donc le le roi n'a
jamais dit tu es tu es moi non c'est
paséit pas son genre c'est pas ça sauf
que les Américains craignaient beaucoup
ce personnage qui s'agitaiit beaucoup
qui avaient des relations avec la tré
continentale avec La Havane avec la
Yougoslavie avec beaucoup de avec Nero
et qui devenait un personnage du
tiermonde qui menaçait un petit peu la
enfin l'Amérique et la CIA tout ça on
sait pas ce qui s'est passé réellement
tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il est mort
sur la torture et son corps a disparu hm
hm ça fait en France en France et ça
fait un très très très grand choc euh le
général de Gaul était très très très en
colère le roi Hassan i était extrêmement
en colère lui aussi bref mais ça on a
fini par euh réavoir des relations
normales ouais il y a eu la deuxième un
deuxème crise deème crise surollandes
lorsque les la police a débarqué chez
l'ambassadeur du Maroc dans sa résidence
en France oui toujours ani pour
signifier un papier de de police ou de
justice pour le directeur la DST
marocain poursuivi pour torture et
cetera ouais ça ça a été un elle a duré
une bonne année ça a été considéré comme
une agression diplomatique quoi ça sait
pas ça sait pas d'aller chez
l'ambassadeur ouais et et puis de
rentrer comme ça ça étaé très très mal à
droite de la part des des Français et
les amis du Maroc qui est de la France
comme isabeth Guigou
on rétablit les choses àprrai alors euh
la langue française a beaucoup de
beaucoup de de lustres en au Maroc et
d'ailleurs les établissements français
au Maroc sont très fréquentés hein par
les Marocains alors il il faut il faut
quand même tirer une sonnette d'alarme
ouais la langue française commence un
petit peu à à être mal mené par les
familles il y a eu les histoires des
visas
ouais très maladroit qui est pas très
ancien il n'est pas question de venir
s'installer en France pourendre le
travail des Français ni des immigrés il
y a des professeurs de médecine il y a
il y a un procureur du roi il y a un
ancien ministre qui n'ont pas pu faire
le voyage hein parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu
de visa pour venir en France après une
décision qui consistait à à diviser par
deux le nombre de visas accordés au
marocains et c'était une punition
collective tout le Magreb
ça ce sont des des des des choses très
malad droite qu'aucun régime avant
Macron n'aurait fait bien sûr que il
faut qu'il y ait des visas bon pour
savoir qui rentre tard mais quand vous
avez un procureur du Roi qui demande un
visa pour X raison ou un ancien ministre
il va pas venir pour pour occuper un
poste h mais c'était l'umiliation ouais
ça été très mal perçu par les
marocquains il y a eu aussi une
humiliation un niveau personnel l'ancien
ministre ministre de de
l'économie Hafed Alami qui est un
milliardaire un monsieur très riche et
qui a beaucoup d'affaires dont des
affaires en France il a des affaires aux
États-Unis ici il est venu avec son jet
privé au Bourger pour régler ses
affaires et là application des lois
strictes fouille systématique pendant 4h
du jet de ses affaires de son ordinateur
de son téléphone de sa fouille
corporelle c'est duré 4h ou 4h et demi
monsieur l' ancien ministre a repris son
jet et reparti au Maroc mais c'est pas
pour ça que la langue l'enseignement de
la langue française recule au Maroc il
recule parce que à partir de d'octobre
ou septembre l'anglais sera 2e langue
dans le collège après l'arabe oui et
donc français recul d'une d'une et ça
vous le déplorez pas vous qui êtes un
écrivain de langue française bien sûr
que je le déplore mais c'est pas pas que
de d'aujourd'hui euh mais la la France
n'a pas fait grandchose pour défendre la
langue française c'est ça le problème et
pourtant il y a beaucoup
d'établissements de langue française au
Maroc il y a énorm gér d'ailleurs par la
France
établissement qui qui pratique le le
l'éducation française il y a les
Massignon par exemple il y a
le Bref et les Marocains se dispute pour
mettre là-bas leurs enfants et ça coûte
500 € enfin 5000
par enfant par mois ouais c'est pas
donné donc c'est pas donné ouais et
c'est la bourgeoisie qui peut se le
permettre il y a beaucoup de en même
temps
on une espèce de
désagrément désagréable entre la France
et le Maroc a fait que certains ont
commencé à inscrire leurs
enfants dans les universités américaines
anglaises quand ils ont les moyens bien
sûr
d'accord expliquez-moi pourquoi les
relations entre le Maroc et l'Algérie
sont aussi détestable aussi compliqué il
m'est arrivé récemment d'interviewer le
président algérien qui m'a dit qui m'a
répondu à une question on a fermé la
frontière avec le Maroc pour ne pas se
faire la guerre c'est terrible ça il dit
n'importe quoi celui-là c'est pas grave
je vais vous raconter une anecdote ouais
Sacha Guiter le grand Sacha Guiter ouais
il a une pièce qui passe et lendemain il
y a son secrétaire qui qui appelle
maître ne lisez pas le Figaro ce matin
il a quelque chose de très désagréable
sur votre pièce et Sacha du fond de son
bureau il dit et j'imagine que l'Arque
est écrit par quelqu'un à qui nous avons
rendu rendu service avant exactement
maître l'Algérie et le Maroc c'est ça
ouais le Maroc a sacrifié beaucoup de
choses a été vraiment l'arrière pays
pendant la guerre il y a eu la réunion
de Tanger en 58 où les trois parties
nationalistes le FLN l'estiqlal et le
Destour sont réunis à Tanger pour voir
l'avenir du Maghreb dans l'esprit
d'indépendance des trois pays et puis
surtout d'un Maghreb uni dans un sens de
progrès avant il avit islamisme ni rien
à l'époque et se posait à l'époque le le
problème de Tindouf ville marocaine
ouais qui en 1932 a été annexé par la
France parce qu'il y avait découvert du
fer et comme l'Algérie était française
on l'a mis dans le territoire français
d'accord
et qui pose la question bien sûr il fois
indépendant on vous rendra votre votre
vie c'est normal c'est une ville
marocaine ça commencé comme ça d'accord
62 l'indépendance le Maroc était content
65 on POS problème des frontières il y a
la guerre des sables ouais avec
Bella des sables tout a étét tout oublié
bon bomian prend le pouvoir avec un coup
d'état Alger ouais et en 74 il y a le
sommet islamique à Casa Casablanca et là
le
Maroc enfin fait voter une
résolution de la pour récupérer les
territoires sahariens entre les mains de
l'Espagne occupé par l'Espagne h
l'Espagne va quitter le le territoire au
moment où Franco était en train de
mourir mourir on est en 75 il y a la
Marche Verte on avance et on récupère
les
territoires l'Algérie a applaudit c'est
formidable mais bmdian qui nétait pas
Casablanca il y avait beau qui est
représenté se met en colère dit pas du
tout nous on veut une sortie sur
l'Atlantique donc on a besoin du Sahara
Occidental voilà ça commencé comme ça et
c'est comme ça que et cadfi cadfi
donnerit l'argent à financer les le
mouvement poliissario dès le départ
et après
Bonfi parfelu n pas pas continué mais
l'Algérie a continué à financer armé les
poissar jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc vous
considérez que c l'Algérie est un
adversaire dans le contexte
régional alors ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que le peuple algérien adore le
Maroc le Maroc n'a aucune animosité à
l'égard du peuple algérien d'ailleurs
c'est encore une histoire de dirigeants
c'est une c'est une histoire entre une
jein militaire ouais qui a besoin de ça
pour exister ouais et puis un pays qui
veut euh avoir une intégrité
territoriale vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'Hassan 2 et de Mohamed 6 alors Hassan
2 avait très bonne presse en France
parce que il avait une espèce d'aisance
oratoire il apparaissait souvent sur les
écrans on le voit là ici en photo il
connaissait la la la politique française
que mieux que personne sans doute euhi
métis votre roi n'a pas tout à fait la
même image aujourd'hui d'abord parce
qu'on le connaît beaucoup moins bien il
apparaît moins souvent
et je crois pour avoir lu vous avoir
beaucoup lu vous trouvez et entendu
qu'il y a une grande injustice vis-à-vis
de lui non c'estàd que lui contrairement
à son père il n'est pas les médias il
n'est pas la communication ouais c'est
ça la différence hein communique pas
d'ailleurs quand il fait les discours
officiels on voit
que ça le pèse ouais bon mais il
travaille beaucoup ouais il travaille
beaucoup et il connaît très bien tout ce
qui se passe en France et ailleurs il
est extrêmement informé surtout et il a
il est très bien disposé à l'égard de
beaucoup de à l'égard du peuple français
en tout cas il vient très très très
souvent en France il a il a ses
habitudes il a il connaît il connaît les
meilleurs restaurants il connaît les
meilleurs euh librairies il connaît les
les meilleures galeries de P parce qu'il
adore l'art non c'est quelqu'un qui qui
aime la France et
on vous reproche parfois d'être très
très royaliste vous hein moi je suis
avec le roi à 100 % parce que je vous
dire pourquoi% parce que lorsque il y a
eu le coup d'État de 1971 10 juillet
1971 il a été fait par des officiers et
des sous-officiers de l'armée marocaine
que j'ai très bien connu oui j'avais 20
ans j'étais dans une prison militaire
marocaine enfin quand disciplinaire
marocain et était dirigé par ces gens-là
et je sais pertinemment ce qu'ils
auraient fait du Maroc s'ils avaient
réussi les piste ça aurit été l'IRAC ou
la Syrie ni plus ni moins c'est des
brutes la plupart venu d'Indochine il on
fait la guerre d'Indochine comme le
fameux aka qui va participer au au coup
d'État qui sera abattu à Kenitra donc
euh je suis avec le le roi parce que il
travaille beaucoup il aime son pays et
il sert son pays et vous vous êtes vous
de façon acharnée vous opposez et vous
luttez contre l'islamisme pas parce que
d'abord vous avez beaucoup écrit làdus
la press c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
la nature marocaine nous avons un un
rythme alqu qui est très très simple
très modéré en plus les Frères musulmans
au Maroc sous le parti PSD parti justice
et développement ont été deux fois au
pouvoir parce que le roi a respecté la
loi démocratique absolument comme en
France il y avait plus de trucage de
fraude aux élections ils ont gouverné
pendant 10 ans deux législatures
catastrophique qui n'ont rien fait pour
le Maroc ouais et en en même temps ils
essayent un peu de semer l'idéologie des
Frères musulmans qui n'est pas la la
plus progressiste ça n'a pas accroché
non c'est la menace est derrière nous et
derrière vous pour le PSD c'est fini
parce que quand les élections ils
passent de 125 députés à 13 h
vous estimez que le Maroc est alors il y
a autre chose il y a il y a le
terrorisme
ouis on a une police efficace on a un
peuple vigilant tout le monde travaille
tout le monde surveille c'estàd que il y
a pres toutes les semaines un
démantellement de cellules terroristes
qui on fait allégance à da on les on les
prend dev les tribunaux après on les met
en prison et souvent le les gens du
quartier Déon ils voit quelque chose qui
va pas ils appellent la police
donc pourquoi parce que nous un attentat
chez nous c'est la fin du tourisme bien
sûr alors je voudrais vous parler de
votre dernier livre alors vous avez une
une
bibliothèque et un nombre de livres
absolument innombrable je sais combien
vous en avez écrit depuis depuis les
années 60 et puis vous passz par le
prigon courourt que vous avez eu il faut
pas l'oublier avec la nuit sacrée qui
est un livre magnifique et votre dernier
livre qui est sorti il y a pas très
longtemps qui s'app appelle un très joli
titre d'ailleurs les amandes Casablanca
c'est une photographie me semble-t-il
hein de ce qu'est la société bourgeoise
on va dire he quand même certain niveau
marocaine alors là ça se passe à
Casablanca qui est la grande ville c'est
pas la capitale mais c'est la grande
ville marocaine économique voilà et
entre une femme qui gagne très très bien
sa vie qui est
pharmacienneine générique et qui
d'ailleurs gagne mieux sa vie que son
mari d'ailleurs quand il est question de
divorce c'est elle qui doit payer une
pension et pas lui
euh est-ce que c'est le reflet de la
société marocaine tel que alors
l'histoire de l'histoire de séparation
ça c'est c'est un peu partout pareil
mais euh est-ce que ce que vous décrivez
là un un mélange de tradition et de
modernité c'est ça le Maroc
d'aujourd'hui c'est le le comment dire
on est on est déchiré entre d'un côté
les traditions marocaines auquel on
tient parce qu'elles font partie de nos
valeurs ouais et puis cette modernité
qu'on qui vient de l'Occident en général
qui est la bienvenu et qu'on veut
partager avec l'univers c'estàd
finalement on veut être les deux un pied
là un pied là en même temps on narrive
pas à trouver une espèce d'équilibre
et et et le couple vit sur les deux
ouais et parfois c'est de là vientent
les difficultés est-ce que la société
marocaine vous la sentez beaucoup
évoluer on dit qu'aujourd'hui elle a
elle a complètement changé par rapport à
ce qu'elle était alors
elle évolue c'est vrai mais tant tant
que le Parlement n'a pas abrogé deux
articles de loi le 489 et le 490 qui
interdisent l'homosexualité et les
relations sexuelles hors mariage ou on
peut pas dire que le Maroc a changé
ouais moi je milite pour l'avocation de
ces deux de deux articles articles qui
sont stupides d'autant plus que on va
pas on va pas condamner quelqu'un parce
que il a une sucualité différente ouais
c'est stupide c'est il a il a sa vie il
est né comme ça point on a pas à
discuter ouais bon quand au relations
sexuelles de mariage il faut pas être
sorer pour savoir que tous les Marocains
font l'amour avant de se marier ouais
ouais c'est une réalité connue et
reconnue ouai bon mais en même temps ça
permet à la police quand un jeune
marocain avec une jeune femme arrive à
un aôel même 5 étoiles ouis on lui dit
vous avez qui c'est cette femme là ouz
pas le droit de ouais si c'est pas votre
femme dehors sinon vous avez cette femme
donnez-moi le l'acte de mariage ouais
c'est arrivé à des gens très connus vous
déplorez ça mais bien sûr et ça c'est
c'est c'est les derniers comment dire de
c'est le dernier article auquel
s'accrochent les islamistes parce que en
ce moment il y a une révision du Code de
la
famille a une commission qui travaille
et dans cette révision moi je lui Auris
dit il faut absolument qu'on a la
liberté de conscience ouais comme les
Tunisiens est long les Tunisiens et
tunisé c'est pas meilleur que nous et
nous on l'a pas et donc si on n' pas ça
l'évolution est un peu bancale vous vous
estimez vous écrivain franco-marocain
comme un écrivain engagé je suis un
citoyen engagé citoyen vous êtes un
citoyen engagé ouais parce que la
littérature engagée c'est pas très bon
ouais non je suis un citoyen je suis
concerné parce qui se passe dans les mes
deux pays la France et le Maroc j'ai
j'écris beaucoup dans toutes les
semaines une chronique dans le 360 qui
est un peu proche du pouvoir mais où je
dis tout ce que je veux avec liberté
ouais et qui être élu et puis ici je je
critique la politique française quand
quand ça va pas vous êtes à l'Académie
goncour et et vous avez il y a quelques
années posé votre candidature pour être
à l'Académie française et puis vous
l'avez retiré mais cétait avant oui et
vous l'avez retiré pourquoi parce que
euh c'était presque fait mais un soir
Alain DEC mon ami et mon mon protecteur
à l'époque m'a dit tu laisses tomber je
dis pourquoi il m' dit giscar veut le
poste enfin veut le fauteuil ah ouis
c'était pour singor non non c'est c'est
pas grave c'est pas parce que l'Académie
goncour on peut pas aller là-bas c'est
c'est et nous à l'Académie Gour on rend
service à la littérature ou et on rend
heureux quelques auteur c'est très bien
est-ce que il y a des écrivains
maghrébains qui vous ont inspiré ou que
vous admirez ah bah il y a katb Yassine
d'abord qui grand écrivérien mohamedb
aussi la génération Mohamed Dib très
très grand écriv algérien
pubi comme
marocain j'ai lu beaucoup oup tout tout
t tous mes aînés m'ont beaucoup apporté
bien sûr et qu'est-ce que euh vous
retenez de cette littérature maghrébine
c'est souvent une littérature de combat
hein c'est une littérature de rébellion
plutô de combat parce que beaucoup de
femmes écrivent ouis pour dire leurs
conditions insoutenable insupportable et
beaucoup de jeunes aussi écrivent pour
parler d'un Maroc qui aurait pu qui
pourrait être bien mieux que ce qu'il
est actuellement ouais je parle de la
pauvreté je parle de le niveau de la
l'état de la santé du pays ENF dans le
pays l'éducation il y a des problèmes il
y a des problèmes mais par ailleurs le
roi il a fait le maximum il a doté le
pays d'infrastructure extraordinaire et
on a pormet deux pmet sur le Méditerrané
à Tanger qui sont exceptionnels les
autoroutes le
TGV le le le
azazat il a il a construit une très
grande centrale le pour capter la le
soleil le Soleil Central soleil il a
fait beaucoup de choses ouais lui mais
il dans les directives mais il y a il y
a le Parlement il a le peuple ça c'est
c'est autre chose et aujourd'hui le le
Maroc aussi euh regarde beaucoup vers
l'Afrique subsaharienne ça c'est très
important énormément d'investissement en
Afrique subsaharienne ça par amour de
l'Afrique parce que Mohamed 6 adore
l'Afrique et il a un petit peu euh
disons rectifier une erreur de son père
qui n'avait pas une très grande
proximité en dehors de c'est une gore et
faut boignier mais Mohamed 6 il est allé
dans presque tous les États africains il
a sé journé longtemps il a des relations
privilégiées avec beaucoup d'entre eux
et il y a des investisseurs marocains
qui on suivi et il y a le Maroc est
devenu un pays émergent et le relation
entre beaucoup de pays africains et le
Maroc sont
excellentes merci tareloun merci
beaucoup de votre en prie merci beaucoup
à vos
[Musique]
réponses